PROFESSOR: So let's begin to
examine our assumptions having
to do with the transport
of respiratory droplets
in a well-mixed room by thinking
about effects of fluid flow
and transport going
beyond a well-mixed room.
So to begin thinking
about this problem,
it's instructive to think of
examples of simpler flows,
in particular the
canonical problem of flow
past an object--
for example, a cylinder.
Here I've shown a cylinder
placed in a uniform flow field
with increasing speed
and fixed object size.
So as you can see,
at low speeds,
the streamlines are fairly
reversible and simple looking.
And at high speeds, you end
up with very complicated
turbulent flows.
A very simple parameter
controls the transition
between these flow regimes,
which is the Reynolds number.
This is a
dimensionless quantity,
which is a property
of the fluid, which
includes the kinetic
viscosity, for example, of air.
And I'll just write this,
kinematic viscosity.
And it has a measure
of the flow speed.
So we'll call that U. So the
magnitude of the background
flow here is U. And it has some
information about the geometry,
in particular the
size of the object.
So for example, we could
define this based on,
well, let's just say, some
length scale L, which could be,
for example, the
radius of the cylinder.
And in the case of this
cylinder that I've shown here,
if the Reynolds number
is less than around 10,
you're in this regime
here of so-called creeping
flow where you can see
the streamlines are
very simple looking.
And they are reversible.
So they kind of smoothly
conform to the object.
And you can run the flow
in the backwards direction.
You'll get exactly
the same streamlines.
But once you get to a
Reynolds number of around 10,
then you start to see
different effects.
And that's because the physical
interpretation of this quantity
is the ratio of inertia, which
is the tendency for fluid
to want to keep moving
in the same direction
due to its mass
that has been set
into motion,
relative to viscosity
or to viscous stresses.
And that's the
tendency for the fluid
to have some
friction with itself.
If you start to move
a piece of the fluid,
other elements of fluid
nearby are pulling back.
There's some friction.
And it impedes the motion.
So whenever inertia is getting
bigger than viscous stress,
we start to have a
tendency for the fluid
to want to keep going
in the same direction.
And it can lead to
very complicated flows.
In particular here, the first
thing that starts to happen
is the fluid kind of
whizzes past the cylinder
and then starts to have a
recirculation on the back side.
So this happens around
Reynolds number equals 10.
So if you have Reynolds
number greater than around 10,
you have some
vortices are created.
So it's no longer an
irrotational flow.
It has some obvious
closed streamlines.
If we increase the
Reynolds number further,
like in this situation here, we
get to Reynolds number bigger
than around 90.
Then those vortices themselves
are starting to spin fast.
And they also have some inertia.
And they start to separate.
Also the fluid is pulling
those vortices away.
So we have vortex shedding.
And that happens in
an unsteady fashion.
So what happens is there's--
one of these two vortices goes
unstable first and peels away
and starts to move downstream.
The other one kind
of takes its place.
And it's almost like a
flapping flag kind of motion,
where a train of
vortices is released.
So this is an
unsteady situation.
And this is called
a vortex sheet.
But it's basically
an array of vortices
that are being released in
a time-dependent fashion.
And at first, that's a
fairly regular process
when the Reynolds number
is on the order of 100.
But if you keep increasing
the Reynolds number,
that process becomes
more and more chaotic
until there's a transition to
turbulence, which is a fully
chaotic, heavily-mixed flow.
And that happens
through an instability
around Reynolds
number of a 2,000,
where you have a turbulent wake.
So behind the object
or the obstacle,
there is a steady
stream of turbulence
where, as I've tried
to sketch here,
you have vortices and
eddies of all sizes.
So there are eddies
like I've shown here
that are at the scale of
the cylinder, but then much,
much smaller ones, too.
So it's a very complicated,
time-dependent flow field.
So we can see here,
the Reynolds number
has a big effect on
the types of flows
that are generated
and obviously also
on mixing as you go from
low to high Reynolds number.
So let's think about
how that would change
in the setting of indoor air.
So let's look at flow.
Let's look at airflow in a room.
So let's think about
the different scenarios
we could have.
So maybe our first
scenario would be
we have all the windows closed.
There's no movement in the room.
It's essentially a still room.
But as we've discussed
earlier, there's
still some air change
with the outside.
So air is still
leaking to the outside.
There's still a little bit
of instability and movement
also from thermal effects,
which we'll talk about shortly.
So there is a little
bit of flow in the room.
And in particular,
let's just ask ourselves
what happens if we have a
little bit of air exchange
with the outside, which is
this flow rate Q that we've
discussed, but in the case
of natural ventilation
with closed windows.
And in that situation,
we've used as an estimate
that the air change
time, or air change rate,
might be on the order of
0.3 air changes per hour,
which corresponds
to 3 hours' time
to have the room air changed.
So that's a pretty slow pace.
If you consider a room
whose height is 2.7 meters,
just to put a number on it, and
you have that air change rate,
then the average
velocity in the room
is on the order of
1 meter per hour.
So that's a pretty slow pace.
So to go 1 meter, it's going
take a whole hour, so very
slow.
So you think, not much
interesting is happening.
But if you calculate
the Reynolds number
for this situation,
is actually 110
with those numbers.
And that's already
putting us in the regime
of not only forming vortices,
but also having some vortex
shedding.
So even when a room is
rather still, and there's
just some very gentle movement
of air out the windows,
or cracks around the
windows and other places
where the room may
not be tight, or
from some other minor
movement going on in the room,
we already expect to see some
unsteady vortices and movement
of air in that room.
But the situation gets more--
gets much stronger if we now
move to having ventilation.
So let's imagine that we have
an HVAC unit on top-- maybe,
let's say, an air
conditioner, which
is blowing air into the room
perhaps from somewhere above.
So now we have a flow which
is going into the room.
It still has to leave
somewhere, let's say,
through an outlet vent.
And in this case, the flow
rate might be a lot higher.
So let's imagine, now, we
have lambda a would be,
let's say, 8 air
changes per hour.
And this would be
looking at a typical case
of mechanical ventilation.
And what we really care
about here, by the way,
is the total flow rate.
So we're not interested
in just the outdoor air.
So what I really want,
I should mention,
is lambda bar a, where that
is the total air change.
So lambda a bar, we'll define
as the air change due to just
the fresh air-- so
that was the Q over V--
plus the air change due
to the filtration flows.
So there is sort of this
recirculating flow--
and we've written that as Q--
the outdoor airflow plus
the filtration airflow
divided by volume.
So I just want to make sure
we throw that in there,
because you can get some flow
going also by having a HEPA
filtration unit in your room.
And there's circulation
going on from that.
And that does
contribute to mixing.
And so if we now calculate
what is the Reynolds number,
we're now getting
up to around 2,000.
And that's interesting,
because that is already
getting to the regime
of turbulent flow.
So just the velocities and flows
that are generated in the air
from typical air conditioning
or even gentle fans
will lead to turbulent
flows in the room.
And turbulent flows are
very effective at mixing.
So that's one reason we might
expect to see strong mixing.
So what this actually
looks like is--
imagine there's a
person in the room.
There could be a
table and a chair,
some kind of
obstacles in the room.
And even if nobody's moving,
just the flow through the room
is causing some turbulent
wakes and vortex shedding.
And there can be some
circulations, such
that you have some fairly
significant inertial effects
leading to mixing
in that system.
Now, we can also ask ourselves,
what about other ways
that momentum is imparted
to the fluid in a room
with people in it?
Well, it could be, for
example, human movement.
So what if we have--
let's think about
what the Reynolds
numbers might be for that.
So if we have human movement--
let's say, for example,
I'm moving my arm.
Or I'm moving my head.
I'm not even talking about
running or really moving fast.
But let's just think about
this kind of a motion.
I might be moving
with a velocity
anywhere from 10
centimeters, or 0.1 meters,
to 1 meters per second, right?
So I could easily go 10
centimeters in 1 second.
But I could maybe
go a little faster.
And I'm moving a part
of my body, which
might have a length that scales
from, let's say, 10 centimeters
to 1 meter.
So I'm moving maybe my
arm or my hand or my head.
So if we take this range
of values here and ask,
now what's the
Reynolds number, then
the Reynolds number is around
10 to the 3 to 10 to the 5.
So and you know this.
If you have a room where
there's some smoke or some dust
particles that you can
see in the sunlight,
just take your hand and move it
like this, even fairly gently.
You're going to see very
complicated turbulent flows
in the wake of that movement.
So basically, anything
going on in the room
in terms of movement is leading
to substantial complexity
in the flow fields, which
contributes to mixing.
Another one to think about,
which we will come back to,
is human respiration, so the
fact that you're breathing.
So we will come back to
this term more carefully.
But we can still think about it
in terms of the Reynolds number
right now.
So if you imagine just the flow
that is leaving your mouth--
so in this case
your length scale
is on the order of 1 centimeter.
So maybe the area of
your mouth that's open
is maybe several centimeters.
And the velocity
of your breathing
depends on how heavily
you're breathing
and what your activities are.
But it's on the order-- so if I
write this as the velocity U--
I should have
written this as a U
as well, from
actually over there.
So if my velocity scale
is around 0.5 to 2 meters
per second--
that's a typical
respiratory velocity--
then now we find the Reynolds
number is on the order of 10
to the 3 to 10 to the 4.
So again, all these activities
of breathing, motion, anything
humans are doing in
the room, even just
sitting there and breathing
is leading to Reynolds numbers
locally that are on the order of
thousands or tens of thousands,
which means that we are seeing
turbulent flows in the vicinity
of those motions.
So that doesn't mean
that those flows are
enough to mix the entire room.
But certainly in the
vicinity of a person,
there's a lot of mixing just
from the natural movement
and respiration of that person.
And when you add into that
the mechanical ventilation,
there can be very
significant inertial mixing
going on in the air of a room.
So in this simulation, courtesy
of Saint-Gobain Ceramics
and Plastics, we see an office
space containing a number
of workers sitting in cubicles.
And one of them is
an infected person
emitting infectious aerosols.
And the simulation shows you
how those aerosol particles
are transmitted through the
room by forced convection, where
the orange and white
squares represent
ducts of inflow and outflow
in the mechanical ventilation
system.
This video shows
the effect of motion
and also respiration
leading to turbulent flows
by forcing the air to move
at a high Reynolds number.
So in the case of motion,
we see a turbulent wake
behind the moving person.
And for each breath, we
see a turbulent plume
emitted by the momentum
transferred from the breath.
These images are taken by a
schlieren imaging method that
looks at differences in
the density of the air
and visualizes the texture
of the patterns that
are formed in the density.